ils ont la cote en effet booster par
deux ans de pandémie mais pas seulement
la forte demande d'emplois qualifiés
dans le numérique s'explique aussi par
l'omniprésence des réseaux sociaux dans
nos vies et derrière nos écrans des
community managers et développeurs web
même les chargés de communication
doivent maîtriser la création numérique
jordan 26 ans est déjà expérimenté
quelques amis je me vois comme universal
demande amélioré avec vous que les
compétences et attise et quelques voix
proposé sur le marché du travail il veut
de nouveaux débouchés d'autres personnes
et du cru ce cas peut-être en compte
afin de développer de nouvelles
activités en martinique
face au candidat l'association madinina
bikers cherche un chargé de
communication
je trouve que ce sont des jeunes très
motivés et qu'ils aient envie de
défendre un petit peu de leurs
compétences quel que soit le secteur
d'activité tout le monde communique
aujourd'hui sur internet chaque
entreprise cherche soit un prestataire
externe dans la communication soit un
salarié embauché à plein temps et puis
on a des jeunes et des moins jeunes qui
se font qu'ils se forment et qui sont
diplômés du coup de diplômes de
développeurs web ou marketing
communication et c'est donc du coup on a
aussi des community managers donc on a
énormément de formation actuellement
dans la communication effectivement les
offres d'emploi sont submergés de
candidature et les employant 100 content
et pour aider les candidats à se
distinguer la bourse propose ce matin
une expérience originale une photo de
qualité professionnelle pour figurer sur
les cv papier mais aussi en ligne car un
employeur en accorde en moyenne pas plus
de 30 secondes à la lecture du document